the Charlize is preparing to be megyn
kelly we've done the major yeah we did
yeah
that go it went really well movie to
play someone who is alive and we know it
was an arc you know it's an ensemble
piece so it really covers that year or
so right before our Ailes was retired at
Fox so there's a lot of people who were
involved in that what's your take on her
like like do you play her
sympathetically or do you feel like she
dried up layers honest what I think is
the greater truth of the what I've
discovered like that's what I really
altima try to do and well how do you
research her did you meet with her I
didn't meet with her no she's probably
not thrilled that you're playing her in
the sense about that I don't know about
that I mean I tried to not but I think
it's good to have space and a little
perspective our director or writer you
know there was more of a responsibility
for them to do more of that work I
should access to a lot of material and I
didn't have to like cover her life or
anything it really was just a year of
her working at Fox oh and it's a movie
that exposes what goes on at Fox News
yeah that's pretty interesting
yeah are you afraid to do a film like
that when you first get it because the
person is alive and she's in everybody's
awareness yes of course
and then what pushes you through to take
that and take the risk in this case it
was the director Jay Roach who is a
really good friend of mine and we were
weirdly trying to do something else and
as a friend I asked him to read it and
he just really responded to it and I
trust I really trust his opinion
and he ended up wanting to make it with
me and so that was that was ultimately
what pushed me over the line and I was
like okay if I feel like I'm in the
hands of a filmmaker that I trust and
were you a fan of hers did you ever
watch her on Fox News
I am conflicted about her but I also
think that makes for a great human being
I mean people are conflicted about me
you know I think that is very much a
human the human condition what do you
mean people are conflicted about you
who's conflicted about you I think
people have issues with some of my [ __ ]
giant issues with Charlize I mean the
grand scale of people I don't know any
any guy in